huh love running late hey everybody all
right
bear with me for a minute I get to get
the chat up in front of my face I just
got so much stuff going on i hey you
know what I need I need water bottled
right here in Vermont that's good water
Oh so come on and now this thing's take
me forever to load up here we go ah hope
everybody's doing okay huh this come on
and chant show it to me the anticipation
it's driving me up the wall
there it is huh Thank You Freddy
I appreciate that good evening council
person Thank You Ben ah Thank You
3-legged productions goodness well it's
a couple of it's right off the start
I'll take again I like it been driving
all day good to sit down oh goodness
yeah after such a bug my back after
about three hours worth of driving uh
that'll start to get to me
got my wine I mean water I mean red
water loving this shirt it's actually
it's actually a dress not a question but
I like to thank you and your monitors
for keeping comment sections friendly
especially during an election year yes
it's it's work but it's work worth doing
well hello to Massachusetts oh thank you
big man
this boy chats hopping today goodness
love a flowering your hair is that
TARDIS it's actually purple I do not
have a blue hair flat well I have a blue
we issue one but it's not TARDIS blue
how are you you look wonderful I've been
working on my cosplay with your advice
in mind and oh hang on lost it and I
think I've done ok all charity shop
finds oh nice I really do need to hit up
thrift stores more often um part of the
issue for me is that the only thirst
store that's local to me is Salvation
Army which I don't like
patronizing for personal reasons there
isn't a goodwill that close to me so I I
haven't hit up thrift stores with the
regularity that like I'd say a lot of
the people who had performed burlesque
would do and they will occasionally find
some great stuff and I just don't really
get the chance
shout out to LGBTQ community with dwayne
wade ins Dwayne Wade's daughter coming
out as trans oh I know the name Dwayne
Wade I don't know why I know that name
mmm I'm out of the loop on something
enjoyed the capture video you put up in
the break room the song made me think of
Missy as well oh I don't even thought of
that
that's that would have been a good Missy
song - I was really happy with that
catcher video cuz like about half the
timing of like how stuff hit and where
it hit was deliberate and about the
other half of when the timing of the
music and the video was really sweet was
an accidental find like I well let me
try this clip and then I found something
and they're like oh wait this verdict
and it was it was fun to have that that
discovery with it I had a lot of fun
which doctor do you want to seem for the
60th anniversary um you know I'd kind of
like to just see Eccleston come back
love the hey adore at the end yeah I
mean how else could you end any kind of
video that that is about Katra
gonna be in and out because I'm doing my
homework while I watch that seems to me
a rather popular activity there was
somebody else who who mentioned in the
discord that they were going to be doing
homework why cut my hair short like a
guy about my mom does not know I'm trans
yet oh I can make it tough I mean
depending on what your living situation
is like and how you know hard or or
tense things are at home there are you
know shorter haircuts that you can pass
as more feminine than in your own time
you know mess around and get a more
masculine look out of it something to
consider going short does not have to
inherently mean masculine at least as
far as other people in your life are
aware if they're not aware or if they're
not ready to know you know evil ways is
now stuck in my head nothing wrong with
having that song stuck in your head you
can't believe Gallifrey one is in two
days I'm excited and so not ready when
are you flying into LA I'm coming in
Thursday I have a flight that I'm
arriving Thursday afternoon is what I'm
showing up in LA for Gallifrey 1 I'm so
much packing to do tonight it's crazy
because even though I don't leave until
Thursday morning I mean through my
packing tonight because tomorrow I'm
gonna stay over with Liz because her
place is close is about half the
distance between where I live and the
airport so it would save me time getting
there
for a fairly early morning flight need
to catch up on series 12 looking forward
to can you hear me sounds like the
episode was written for me I it's been
you seeing the reactions - can you hear
me have been really odd because I did
what I always do I fill my review before
I saw anyone elses reactions and because
a lot of the youtubers that I follow
in the UK they all had their videos up
before I even saw the thing but in this
case like watching them after the fact
he was like did you guys watch a
different episode from me it was really
weird and was a little bit surreal I
think something slightly similar
happened when it takes you away aired
except I wasn't following as many who
tubers at that point so as as opposed to
one or two who didn't quite connect with
it the way I did it's like five or six
I'm like huh so that that was odd
initial thoughts on birds-of-prey if
you've seen it I have seen it review up
Friday short version I like it let's see
oh sorry that I'm trying to keep up with
the chat but it is speeding by not trams
but in not trans but am experimenting
room my hair longer for the first time
ever I did that basically as soon as I
was out of high school because the high
school I went to had a hair length
restriction so as soon as I graduated I
started letting my hair go and that was
you know I had I hadn't actually really
done much with his flooring even
cross-dressing for a while at that point
and I certainly wasn't thinking of
myself in any sort of non cisgender
terms so like by all means great hair
out but my hair actually still is not as
long as it was at its longest um you
know when I was in my twenties mom would
be accepting but don't want to surprise
her I get that I kinda had a similar
thing with my mother it was a while
before I mean initially I just came up
to my mother as a crossdresser and it
was a while before I did that not
because I had any fear of her reaction I
knew she'd be accepting and would love
me no matter what and course she did but
just knowing that she was gonna have a
lot of questions and early days I didn't
know what the answers were and I didn't
want to make her nervous or
uncomfortable
thoughts on Graham getting brushed off
okay I want to talk about that like to
the point that I actually think I am
going to I think I'm actually gonna
shoot a video and I'm probably just
gonna put it up on the breakroom because
I I'm not sure it'll be enough to
warrant the normal channel but I did not
read the 13th Doctor is brushing him off
I really didn't and so to see so many
people being really upset about that
that I mean more than just the people
not not connecting to the metaphor or
seeming to not pick up on the metaphor
of that episode that I was seeing
elsewhere
the number of people really pissed about
the way that moment went down that
caught me off guard cuz I did not read
that scene or that moment the way so
many other people did does that mean I'm
right not necessarily but it did mean I
was so blindsided by that that threw me
off massively I did not read it as a
brush-off
I think Vincent and the doctor wasn't so
beloved on initial airing at least to my
memory that's my memory as well but it's
also a while it's tricky to know I'm
knitting myself a handmade Newt
Scamander scarf Oh that'll be fun hmm
uh no Liam Jodie Whittaker is not the
worst doctor in my personal opinion she
I mean first of all I'm not gonna do a
ranking video um until her eras done but
broadly speaking I like her better than
Davison I can I can say that much at
least
so is she in the upper half no not yet
but I also have been settled for the day
where did the doctor supposedly brush
him off okay so at the end of the
episode Graham is talking to the doctor
about
his fears about his cancer coming back
and the doctor doesn't say anything
initially and what she ends up saying is
you I forget the exact words but the
gist of it is you know I'm not really
good at this I'm gonna I'm just gonna
walk over it to the console fiddle with
a few things and in a few minutes I'll
think of what I should have said and a
lot of people read that as a brush-off
or heard dismissing him or in some way
being unable or unwilling to try and
lend him comfort none of which were the
way in which I read that so like I said
I'm pretty sure that actually I think as
soon as I'm done with the live stream
I'm gonna shoot a quick video to put up
on the break room and talk about how I
read that scene because I got something
completely different from a lot of
people what did you think of the Oscars
and the surprise performance by mm um
confession time I didn't watch the
Oscars as they aired I actually
basically had them live texted to me but
Liz as she watched them so I know the
results I didn't watch it
um the results were actually quite
pleasantly surprising in a lot of
categories so that was nice
what happened did the other council of
geeks members their kids so wrangling
people is tough I still I I would like
to have them um back on the channel
again it's just I have a kid they have
kids I work a job they work jobs you
know trying to just try trying to
organize schedules and find a topic that
we can that we all want to talk about
and to sit down and have us do it and
you know have that topic not be
something that's super topical that I
got to turn around real quick cuz that's
even harder to pull together it's just
it's just tough I mean that's that's
kind of all all that I can say about
that I bummed me out how long it's been
since I've had somebody else on the
channel including Liz
I would have loved to have had her on
for the Little Women review but yeah
it's tough what culture scene to the
think the moment was out of character
which I really disagree with this
doctors really not been keen on getting
personal with companions again I'm gonna
do a video on it I think love your
dressing your hair Thank You Freddie
let's see
I thought you watch the show oh are you
gonna try and watch next year's Oscars I
mean I I don't know I I for reasons not
worth getting into I skipped the Oscar
um
pool that I normally do well actually
I'll backtrack I I missed the deadline
to get my pics in I wouldn't have done
that well this year anyways and and I
ended up not being able to go to the the
party and wow I did miss it
you know I don't know if I missed it
enough to like have to go super out of
my way to be sure I catch it again next
year I the simple truth is the only
reason I continued to care about the
Oscars at all was because I was in an
Oscar but I was in an Oscar pool with
money riding on it and I was going to a
party to watch it other than that I
haven't really I haven't really cared
about the Oscars that deeply in a while
what will your Excuse be to avoid
getting drafted hypothetically up being
being outside the age range I'm looking
down the barrel at 40 in a couple years
folks I'm not draft age I don't like can
you hear me because those gods were so
easily defeated it was so anticlimactic
also Aleppo was redundant it was not
needed at all I don't think a loophole
was redundant in any way I think it
served a similar purpose to the other
scenes we saw and it was and it served
to reinforce the themes already there I
will concede that the resolution was a
little quick and I
I've seen a number of people say that
they thought the episode would have
benefited from being a two-parter and
I'm not gonna argue that it wouldn't be
but I would think how quickly they were
dealt with is the one area that needed
more time to just have it take longer to
do I will absolutely grant that
criticism it didn't pull the episode
down for me because everything else was
connecting so hard but that one that one
I kind of kind of just give you that one
like yeah if that was an issue for you I
get it
I would have gotten rid of Aleppo and
built up the nightmares stuff companion
stuff more that would have been an
option again
I thought the illiberal stuff worked
personally there is no way here almost
40 hook mid to late-20s I will be 38 in
March Cheers
oh and somebody asks this is a citizen
cider good stuff you'll have to forgive
me this the chat is going by so fast
tonight I'm not gonna scroll back up and
try and catch the stuff that I missed so
if I miss a question ask it again maybe
I'll catch it next time
thoughts on the piece of art movements
during the Renaissance and could you
answer before 10:00 a.m. tomorrow in
detail just curious I see what you did
there
clever bugger nearly 40 surely not mmm
closer to 40 than I am to anything else
at this point closer to 40 than I am to
35 I felt the same way about this
episode of thought people would have
liked the episode of more especially the
villains have you seen the musical
Heather's know I've seen drag queens do
a lip-sync number to one of the songs
from the musical Heather's I have not
seen the actual thing I'm not sure could
live up to that
so fellow Aires yes indeed barely I am
barely in Aires I was born on March 21st
midnight in three minutes four minutes
earlier and I
to Pisces so yes I'm an Aries but I'm
like the cuss piaced
Aries you will ever come across the
counter that other question is Jody the
best doctor so far no Capaldi is but I'm
finding more Merritt and Jody as it goes
along my brother's birthday is in March
well I hope he has a happy birthday
someone raised a good point a few weeks
ago that the doctor yeah backing up that
the doc can take Graham to a future
where he can get his cancer cured I mean
yes you can his cancer is not an issue
right now though so that's a pure
hypothetical I'm guessing the song was
candy store good guess Quinn very nice
any theories on the fact that not a
single series 12 stories has left earth
as a primary location yet why does that
need a theory series one didn't leave
earth either I mean what that's another
thing that struck me as an odd hang-up
this series a lot of people are bringing
that it up and like I'm someone who
likes to go offworld um it actually it
really annoy me series 8 felt incredibly
earthbound to me and that one actually
did go offworld but the reason that one
felt so worthwhile to me is it felt like
every dang episode he had to go back and
get Clara again and we never just had an
adventure and the TARDIS he had to start
by convincing her to come with him again
so that annoyed the heck out of me but
just the fact that they're on earth the
stories have been varied enough and the
settings and the challenges and
everything has been wonderfully varied
I've been fine with them being set on
earth wearing more Ansari
whereas Gallifrey 1 uh held never been
may go 2021 Gallifrey 1 is in Los
Angeles that is where that is held the
so this will be my first time going the
same birthday as my BFF oh cool I said I
wouldn't scroll back for questions and
now I'm doing exactly that
I'm so bad at sticking to my own things
while you're ten years older than me
never would have guessed aw shucks
would you ever consider growing out your
hair on the back and the sides I'm maybe
I like I like this though I enjoy it I
mean right now I just I don't have a
reason to do that do you think Ruth is
the value no no I don't I nothing what
is it I don't think she is I don't think
she's Jenny I don't think he's connected
to the gang or doctor she's the doctor
some way and I know yes the value does
the duck I don't think she's the value
absolutely love your analysis of can you
hear me spot-on with the metaphor about
depression a really great review also
you look amazing nice dress Thank You
Jamie
my birthday was last Saturday Oh Cassie
I hope you had a great birthday now that
the UH the Eternals are back which
specific ones do you think will be good
to also bring back toymaker
I want death to make an appearance I'm
not actually necessarily gunning for any
specific ones to return I just like that
the idea of things more powerful than
the time lords got reintroduced cuz I
was gonna say I've been missing that I
don't think I realized I missed it until
it kind of came back that it's like oh
yeah Liam look I'm not trying to dodge
your questions but I don't really like
the very leading way in which your
wording them if you want my opinion on
something just ask me my opinion don't
give me this would you agree that and
then throw out what I'm presuming is
your opinion I don't ask me questions
like that don't leave me I'm gonna I'm
gonna resent it on principle regardless
of what my opinion is
couldn't Ruth doctor be the doctor's
daughter who wouldn't know I mean what
like she could but I don't think so
and that would be a cheap trick I think
people are saying the Mary Shelley
episode will have Cybermen what about
you oh I hadn't thought of that it would
actually make a certain amount of sense
because there is um
you know there is a passing resemblance
to the concept of Frankenstein and the
idea of what goes on with the Cybermen
it's not a one-to-one it's not even
close but they're not a million miles
apart so maybe I don't think so though
cuz the the implication seems to be that
the Cybermen are gonna be tied up in the
finale so like maybe they get introduced
I don't think they're gonna be central
to the story of that one though um I
have a problem with the new episode
because it feels like I've seen it
before it's a mix of ideas from the
impossible plan and then I may our man
from Sarah Jane Adventures okay I don't
really have a problem with remixed ideas
as long as they are in fact remixed if
you're literally just taking a plot that
you did before and doing it again that
will bother me but I think like I don't
demand 100% originality out of every
episode they're allowed to revisit and
remix and pull stuff in but again if
that hurt the episode for you that's
fine I get it uh-huh this chat is really
annoying me today um based off what
you've seen so far a weirwood series 12
rank for you um I don't know overall
definitely better than eleven like that
that's an easy call and the grand scheme
I don't know I a lot is gonna be riding
on the finale and the answers to the
questions specifically around Routh how
those questions get answered is gonna
make or break this series which is why
I'm nervous
Mike Chibnall break the lore for the
series 12 finale it depends on what you
consider to be lore breaking
there are some people who will claim
that some things break lore that I would
say no it tinkers with lore and it
contradicts the generally accepted fan
interpretation of lore but when you
actually or or it contradicts a Big
Finish or novel or but not TV show so
whether or not whatever happens in the
finale breaks lore is going to depend on
how you personally define your lore um
might he yes he might depending on what
he does and how he does it it may or may
not break anything again we're gonna
have to kind of wait and see I think
give me from icarly hey okay not sure
why that came up this darn thing come on
have you seen shits Creek
I have nots not really my style of show
um out of the nominees what was your
pick for Best Picture I didn't really
have one
I hadn't seen many of them out of the
ones I've seen I would have gone with
Little Women but I still would see
parasite and I absolutely need to so
well I I don't want to see that with Liz
though the episode didn't seem to imply
that those gods could escape again since
the first one wasn't captured for some
reason does that mess with the metaphor
I don't think so because in theory the
first one should have shouldn't have
been able to escape but just because you
found a way to stop it from escaping the
same way it did last time doesn't mean
it can't escape again that's a little of
extrapolation on my part I grant and
whether you think that's asking too much
of an audience to go with a metaphor
your call but for me that doesn't break
it rainbow Guardians based off what
you've seen so far
oh no that got asked again I'd like to
see the Ronnie I don't like the Ronnie I
really don't I mean I'm not gonna see
there's no potential in the idea and I
suppose if they ever brought her back
there are things that they could do or
ways that they could reinterpret the
character and and have it work but I've
never liked the Ronnie do you think
Moffat had stopped screaming to pill yet
after the ravine spot fall part two I
don't I don't think Moffat would be
begrudging that I mean Moffat completely
messed with stuff that seemed to be what
Davies was doing you know it I don't I
don't know the man kind of an odd
question I love your glasses where did
you get that the glasses are from xeni
optical ze NN I ah hold on let me get
you know what I gotta stop trying to
catch up I got to get down to the
current spot of the thing and go from
there remember Russell T Davies 86
schalke PS no love for the lighthouse
well yeah I mean look when something
runs as long as Doctor Who it's actually
amazing that they haven't had to
completely uproot lore more often I mean
if you're gonna talk comparable
characters running in theoretically
continuous stories like comic books have
had to retcon and reboot so often with
characters who've been around for
comfortable amounts of time the fact
that doctor who has done it as little as
it has is kind of impressive
well the timeless child drew the
Cybermen be connected something like the
silenced artists exploiting cracks in
time
I mean I'm expecting they will be how I
have no idea if there were to be a 60th
anniversary special with any three
doctors which would you like them to be
well if we're gonna talk realistic than
it has to be doctors who the actors are
still around I would go
well you have to have the current doctor
so the first question would be whether
or not would occur still on the part but
whoever the current doctor is and then
I'll take Eccleston and McCoy I think
there's actually an 8th doctor audio
drama called the silver Turk in which 8
meets Mary Shelley and there's body
horror Cybermen plot elements I wouldn't
be shocked if they actually pulled from
that I mean they've they've pulled story
elements if not in tires concepts from
the audios before I mean Dalek was
originally Jubilee so that wouldn't even
be a new trick if you could guest write
an episode of Doctor Who what story
would you like to write and why oh I I
have no idea I like I've had a few
general concepts like a Doctor Who that
I would like to see them do but like I
don't have a Doctor Who story in my head
I think enough time into trying to wrap
my head around my own dang stories
Pertwee's son is alive the right age and
bares enough for resemblance to his
father to play three I agree but I I
feel I need to go back and check I feel
like he said at some point that he
doesn't want to do that cuz I think he's
been asked not like formally to do it
but like by media or fans or something I
could be wrong about that but when will
you rank series 6 also when what is the
next classic who review on the podcast
okay
two things there first the ranking video
comes out tomorrow
normally it would have been a Sunday
release but because I'm doing the new
episodes it's gone
slot in on the Wednesday so that comes
out tomorrow as far as the next classic
ooh I think just just trying to get
ahead of things I think I'm actually
gonna do a big finish instead because
that's something I can listen to on the
plane to Gallifrey 1 and actually get it
done
so I'm actually one of the things on my
to-do list when once I get off this is
to put together a poll for the for the
patreon page to have a to have the
patrons vote on which Big Finish audio
that I'll review so that's probably what
it'll be next Star Trek fans can also
get really fussy about continuity well
they're kind of the they're kind of the
classic example of continuity nuts you
know it's it's it's the the classic sort
of nerd cliche of you know somebody in a
Starfleet outfit getting out of qat with
William Shatner and asking him technical
continuity questions about the starboard
nacelle yeah my grade went from an F to
a B because I took a quiz I missed Wow
that quiz counted for a lot didn't it
which would you say is the worst master
story I used to think it's death in
heaven despite Missy being awesome but I
need to re-watch and see more classic
who um there's a lot of classic whose
stories with the doctor that I haven't
seen yet so if you're asking for a worst
of all time I don't know if you're
asking me for a worst of modern era I'm
sorry I'm gonna say sound of drums last
of the Timelords I got a lot of problems
for that thing for troll repellent oh
thank you beach girl yes the mods are
working overtime on the trolls tonight
good job all of you
Karen pirates Joel thank you kindly
you do good work all have you ever read
Russell T Davies book the writers how
about series 4
The Specials know I've been meaning to
for friggin ever I it's it on audio or
is it only in print cuz if it's on audio
like I would snatch it up in a heartbeat
but if it's only in print I don't know
when the heck I'm gonna get to that
applause for the mods yes absolutely
most epic classic who story um if I'm
gonna assume that you're not just using
epic as a synonym for goodie you're
actually saying like big scale scope big
epic story um for my part out of the
ones I've seen ah probably pyramids of
Mars which is anyone one I like all that
much would you like to see Russell T
Davies and Moffat return to write an
episode or two in the future um yes and
no so that there's two answers to that
there's my personal feelings answer and
then there's in the interest of the show
answer my personal feelings yes I'd be
all for it I think it'd be fun I would
like to see what they would do with
someone like Jodie Whittaker or you know
whoever comes later do I think they
actually should know because all that's
going to do is throw fuel onto the fire
of fire chip no get rid of Jodie bring
them back yeah I'd like selfishly I
don't want to deal with it
so I happy to be able to catch a live
stream at last it's half-past one here
hi everyone whoa Barbara goodness get
some sleep afterward after we wrap up
here we are gonna have a hard stop at at
8 o'clock Eastern Time because I like I
said I have a lot of packing to do
excuse me ma'am the water came back a
little bit geez all right I was gonna
hop over to the discord and see what
questions had come up over there except
because my computer is really really
starting to worry me I I had to
completely reinstall browser so let me
get this up and running oh good it did
save my password information yay okay so
that's working I'll pop back there in a
minute
best way to hang a poster or holes on
the wall are out of the question but not
preferable also can't peel off paint you
got to get um I forget what it's called
there this is sort of this sort of tacky
putty um but you just sort of ball up
and you stick in the corners that's what
I recommend I personally like them to
bring back from mana cuz she's awesome
maybe regenerated as a man your thoughts
on that could be reveal like Missy um I
don't know I'm very I'm honestly kind of
reluctant to bring back any more
Time Lords than we already have you know
specific ones I mean it's part of the
same reason I'm hesitant to bring back
the Rani I mean like the simple truth is
I don't like a lot of the things that
involve Time Lords other than the doctor
and occasionally the master Romana was
great in her time I'm not sure there's a
ton of benefit to bringing her back
especially if you're not gonna have well
the ward
you know reprise the role not to mention
it would completely screw with my head
canning because my head Canon is that
the woman from end of time is Romana
everyone else says it's the doctor's
mother they're wrong or at least in my
head they're wrong you can't tell me
otherwise because nothing in the episode
confirms who it is I don't care what
Davey said
ah Pater Noster gang uh I'd be up for
them coming back it's been a little
while why is the chat doing that hang on
I need to reload this cuz this is
technology it hates me I feel like it's
been a little while since I've mentioned
that but it's still a fact it hasn't
changed
Omega yes Omega I would like to come
back especially because like it's just a
friggin mask it's not like you're gonna
notice that oh they didn't bring back
the original asker you just stick a big
friggin helmet on them do you think that
Ryan will leave at the end of the series
recent episodes point to it do you think
grandma nor yaz will leave as well I I
don't know I was like my big prediction
was gram was gonna die at the end of the
last series and I was wrong so I don't
know at this point have you ever met any
of the actors from Doctor Who yes I've
met John Barrowman I met him at terrific
on and I will be meeting a few people at
Gallifrey one pictures will be posted a
Corden to extending Universe material
Time Lords are sterile and new children
okay oh god the looms see that's what
I'm talking about that's the sort of
thing that I'm talking about I don't
care if they contradict the looms
I really don't and it's not because I
think the looms are somehow a stupid
idea I just think it would be a stupid
idea to restrict what the show can do
because of that concept which has never
found its way onto the screen all on
backing up not even run stable the the
fatuous PS drusilla actress performed as
Romana 3 oh I did hear that
that's an audio that's what she did
I haven't heard any of those yet
I've forgotten about that I think in
terms of switching things up instead of
bringing back companions they should try
introducing new companions from
different times and planets rather than
21st century earth Joel I've been saying
that for freaking ever they've gotten a
little bit better because specifically
what I used to complain about is that
all of the companions were were except
for Donna they were for a long time
young attractive from modern-day England
Donna broke that slightly by not being
as young you know series Stan had
nardole but he was very much secondary
companion to Bill when thirteen came
around we've got Ryan we we've got
Graham so we've broken the female part
of that but they're still all coming
from the same Dame place I just think of
the fact of how much more I would have
enjoyed Clara if we'd gotten the
governess version of her or Oswin
instead of the version we got stuck with
who was way less interesting not just
because she was from modern-day earth
but that didn't help oh I'm gonna be
getting to Clara soon on the rewatch
will you look at the magician's look
it's on my list with 50,000 other things
someday maybe
look I'm I don't say this to be
mercenary about it but it's the
honest-to-god truth if you really want
me to watch something you got to
Commission me to watch it otherwise I
can't promise when the heck I'll ever
get to it how dare you imply Catherine
Tate isn't as attractive as building
paper I did not say she was less
attractive I said she wasn't as young I
did not mention attractive at all I only
talked aged don't you reject on me uh
think you can pay him from the 80s as
overdone as that era is yeah I'm kind of
done with a deist
hopefully I'll still be okay with wonder
woman 84 but after that like can we
break you have one of my favorite you
have one of my favorite traits going in
depth of explaining oh thank you ready
just you know the the result of wage of
many hours in reality spend rambling you
get good at it after a while
am I the only one who thinks the point
of the doctor falls wasn't that the
master was dead forever is that the
Masters chance of redemption was gone
forever
and Missy herself died that strikes me
as a slightly odd interpretation because
it was only the old you older version
that was doomed to happen to be without
redemption and given that the that Missy
you was going to go back some people
think that you know she didn't get
Redemption because you didn't go back
and actually help but she was going to
you know she made that decision and I
think making that decision is a form of
redemption is it is all-encompassing as
actually going forth and doing the thing
know but making the decision to do the
thing is a big step especially for her
should unit or torch would be back um
somebody should be back it's weird with
both being gone there's there is kind of
a void right now without hope without
witness without reward thank you exactly
may I recommend the Big Finish
Torchwood episode corpse day you said
sky man and children of Earth were the
darkest things come out of Doctor Who
well this one is a huge contender
well then then that would that would go
on the list of when I'm in a headspace
where I think I can deal my opinion the
the music over the past new series has
been not much beyond nice and
serviceable nothing particularly
memorable that reaches the heights of
the are Thierry rtd era Murray gold at
the moment the thing is it's not trying
to do that the music right now is
fundamentally doing very different
things than what Maury gold did now if
it's not your preference fine but it's
not even trying to compete with the Mari
gold bombast it's trying to be
background it's trying to be mood it's
trying to be atmospheric as opposed to
really hammering in on whatever the mood
of the piece is and for what it's trying
to do I think it's actually pretty
successful again if you want to make the
argument that you don't like what it's
doing as much as what merggle did fine
but I still think for what the music is
now being used for it is good at it are
you going to re-review day of the doctor
yes I once I catch up to where I've
actually done reviews I will probably
still keep going because it has at this
point still been a while since I've seen
series eight nine ten even didn't be a
couple years at this point so yeah I'll
continue on what do you think about
Torchwood miracle day should it be a
racer began or maybe you enjoyed it um I
still haven't seen Miracle Day so I have
no opinion no no I really like the music
I don't think practice would have worked
as well with Gold's music I didn't
really know wow I was gonna say I didn't
really notice the music and practice but
that was kind of my point the the music
is way less intrusive than it was with
gold um and you can say that that makes
it less memorable and yeah in a way but
it's also not trying to be memorable I
love that it back-to-back comments are I
adore Mahler miracle day God don't watch
Miracle Day would you like the Sarah
Jane Adventures in Doctor Who or another
series of Sarah Jane Adventures
I don't really have the nostalgia for
the Sarah Jane Adventures that a lot of
people have I watched the first two
series of it but you know I was well out
of the age range it was intended for and
I really felt the 4kids nature of it
started to wear on me after a while
which is not to say it's bad it just
meant that like I was well aged out of
the target demographic so like I don't
have a particularly strong affinity for
Sarah Jane Adventures I I like that it
exists I'm certainly glad it was
successful but it wasn't my thing what I
mean is Missy overall will never get to
enjoy being the good version she became
which is what makes it tragic the master
overall not just Missy will never be
redeemed well that's life I know what
else to say if you talk about the music
I think that a first 13s theme was
supposed to be played oh god dang it I
wish this thing would stop scrolling
played only in the woman who fell to
earth but now is played like it was
Marie gold I I hadn't noticed
by the time you finish with the mat and
Capaldi heirs with overdue who will
enough time I pass the continuous series
11 and even 12 I don't know I'll make
that call when we get there how are you
I am just fine Jason actually I got a
pop over to the discord and take a look
at the questions that might have been
put there because plug the discord the
Council of geeks discord is a patreon
exclusive perk and there is the live
stream prep there while while I do try
and keep up with
questions in the chat and I absolutely
answer the super chats the the only way
to guarantee that I will answer a
question is to have it up in the discord
any other way you again the discord is
to be on the page you're on hey
capitalism alright let's see I can
actually make this one I'll probably be
choirs his I'm catching up on homework
see I told you there was someone else
doing homework um I haven't seen the
Oscars just read through who was
nominated who won don't really have an
opinion at the moment when it comes to
Doctor Who my opinion on the current and
previous series is like yours on the
doctor twelve is better than eleven oh
well said so can we now officially call
Joker the Oscar bait role of comic book
movies it does seem to have become that
doesn't it how pissed off is Jared Leto
do you think that the person who played
the part before him got an Oscar
personally the part after him got an
Oscar and nobody wants to see him play
it ever again let's see won't make it
tonight
so thirteen obviously landed the TARDIS
pretty close if not actually in New York
City and Nikola Tesla's night of Terror
the New York City that was supposedly
impossible for eleven to reach ever
again oh okay so this has to do with the
end of angels in Manhattan I haven't
gone to the rewatch of that yet but I
was pretty sure that it wasn't just New
York has location it was a specific
chunk of time in New York so I'm pretty
sure that Nicolas hustle was far enough
ahead of the events of angels in
Manhattan that if that doesn't become a
contradiction I think that is it Oh
someone went down the wrong pipe it's
almost money in my time I'm traveling
about a lot tomorrow I should probably
get some shut-eye this is where I bow
out for now Joel I have you sent me the
thumbnail for tomorrow's video yet I
hadn't checked I'm hoping you did what
sort of equipment you use for recording
hang on I'll show you so this the canon
g7x which was the camera i got about a
year ago thanks to patreon yay
so I like this camera in a lot of ways
there's a couple of things that annoy me
about it it burns through its battery
really quick which annoys me there's a
couple of quirks about it but as far as
the video quality goes I'm very happy
with this anything more intensive than
that would've been wasted on me because
I'm not tech savvy enough to take proper
advantage of something that would have
been you know higher end than that and
this this is a rode videomic rode ro de
and this I have never replaced this is
the same mic I've been using since the
beginning of the channel because I
sprang for a decent mic right at the
start of the whole dang thing because I
learned the hard way that yes yes yes I
have sent it a few hours back okay I
didn't checked yet just just being sure
Thank You Joel I learned the hard way
that ultimately people will be way more
forgiving about
mediocre video quality then they will
about mediocre audio quality there was
an independent film that I was in in New
York and they had the cast screening and
it looked decent but you couldn't hear a
the audio was awful and I'm just sitting
there in this in this theater that they
rented out to do the cast screening in
just thinking oh dear God and that and
that was an immediate harsh lesson harsh
lesson of when you are low tech when you
are a low budget people will understand
if your video quality is not the best
ever
but if people can't hear you they're not
gonna stick around
you really can't work with that
Nathaniel as the master veer is the
doctor if I was any better at proper
filmmaking I would totally make a make a
video out of that but I like the idea of
the Eternals power over mental states
and dreams as a nice counter to
Whitaker's over reliant on tech doctor I
haven't thought of her as being over
reliant on tech I think yeah she kind of
is I actually would say that she's been
way more dependent on the Sonic than has
been the case so like Matt Smith used it
a lot but it wasn't usually what solved
the final problem it has been a few
times with Whittaker
I've watched Doctor Who since I was 5
2009 God now I feel don't feel old but I
haven't properly watched a whole season
since series 9 would you recommend watch
the last three series huge fan of the
channel well yes I love series 10 like
straight up legitimately I love series
10 on abassin massively no
qualifications series 11 I have issues
with quite a few do I still think is
worth watching yeah especially
considering it now helps to know series
12 is better so far then series 11 was
so I think it always helps it makes it
easier with I can help with the head
Nathaniel Master Vera doctor yep Oh Joe
John
John is uh has it has a thing going on
lately of a floating ideas at me that
may that make me go I don't know if I
have time for that but I want to do it
you're trouble
John I love you to death and I mean that
the best way uh do you use Twitter yeah
at council of geeks pretty
straightforward uh oh geez it is almost
eight find the time I'm trying man huh
ah what do you think is the best for
Stockton fourth doctor story city of
death huh oh god I love you too
uh when she fought the Daleks used the
energy shield and she used her knowledge
of crass ghost technology vortex
manipulator and implant in the head to
confront him you know before um Ryan
leaves the TARDIS I need some
consequences um cries go that he
basically shot a guy into the distance
pass for him to die against the wishes
of the doctor and there has been zero
consequences to that the doctor has
never found out that he did it
there's been no consequences from the
actions itself ticking me off I'm really
annoyed by that at this point I had
issues with Rose even before that it's
it's a very noble attempt but I had some
pretty personal issues with it but like
the fact that that still has not come
back around really really is annoying me
what's the patreon there for if not to
buy it artists I see I haven't set that
tier goal yet I'm still pricing that out
I'm getting estimates
Truth or Consequences Timelords kidnap
little doctoral master they were
siblings and learn how to regenerate
from them then they erased their
memories that's my theory for timeless
child I've heard something similar and
if that ends up being the case I'm going
to be so I will have to drive my car out
to the country and scream if they do
that I love city of Death and Julian
Glover is coming to Granite State Comic
Con this year oh I don't know that we
New Hampshire never really get cool
people at the one con that much hey at
least you still have a con Vermont Comic
Con doesn't even happen anymore I hate
the IMDB reviews of can you hear me oh
don't look at IMDB reviews I am TV is
getting has been getting a review bombed
since about 2014 like at about the
height of the Marvel DC Wars yeah that
don't don't
yeah just don't it is 8 o'clock you
should be ending soon yeah yeah I should
huh with the complaints about the number
of convenience currently in this series
who is your favorite thing camping and
TARDIS team possible rank review well I
haven't been that many three companion
teams it was what it was it was Ryan yaz
Graham
it was Adric Nessa Tegan
I forget what other times they've had
three people I like like three
companions
I doesn't really work for me
would you like to see Leto's Joker
returned to face Harley Quinn and the
future as a villain no no no I have no
no use for Leto's Joker like ever
I just don't okay I do need to end I
need to wrap up
I have packing I have editing I've got
I've got stuff to do um so thank you
everybody for tuning in
thank you Karen Thank You Joel thank you
pirates for keeping on top of the trolls
there seemed to have been quite a few of
them tonight so cheers to cheers to you
all thank you John for popping in just
to needle me and to to getting into more
projects you bastard and I don't even
consider that that much of an insult I'm
a bastard proud of it anyways uh I hope
everybody had Jed Oh want letter once
the Oscar little has an Oscar whatever
anyways hope everybody has a good night
thank you for tuning in I would say
watch the the Instagram for council of
geeks cuz that's probably where a fair
amount of pictures and stuff that I take
for from Gallifrey one is gonna end up
turning up before I eventually get
around to like cutting a video together
like I did for terrific on and hope
everybody has a good week and I will see
you in two weeks for the live stream so
thank you for tuning in thank you for
watching you are beautiful you are valid
you are loved you are the counsel I'm
just running meetings
have a good night